[Music]
Camila Cabello and Sean Mendes caught
locking lips at Coachella oh my God like
we're we're kissing now a source tells
E.T that the exes are not back together
but there is still a connection between
them oh my God this is a real thing the
two were spotted at the music festival
in Indio California on Friday chatting
it up and sharing drinks with friends
but then things got a little more steamy
between the exes with a video making the
rounds online showing the two making out
[Music]
together
that's Sean with his arms wrapped around
Camila and later the two were seen
walking with their hands on the small of
each other's backs so what does it all
mean our source says the singers knew
they were both heading to Coachella and
had plans to meet up and hang out saying
Sean and Camila had been in touch the
last few weeks and have cleared the air
about their breakup we don't really put
any rules or boundaries I think the
truth about being celebrities and being
in a relationship is that it's super
tricky because there's a lot of people
who want to know more personal stuff of
course the two called it quits in 2021
after more than two years of dating
those feelings are gonna come and I
think you just gather more and more
tools to cope with them in like healthy
ways
[Music]
afterwards Camila dropped her track bom
bom which is largely believed to be
about her breakup from Sean
[Music]
and she opened up to ET about how her
new music was helping her navigate life
after heartbreak that's life you're on
the ground crying in the bathroom floor
and then you'll
have feelings for another person again
and then you'll be crying on the
bathroom floor again and that is kind of
like the cycles of of change like things
just change you never know what's around
the corner now ET Source says the love
and care is still there but it's very
casual at this point I'm not girlfriend
but very close friend as for that smooch
our source says they let loose during
night one of Coachella and we're just
having fun so should we hold out hope
for Sean Mila 2.0 according to our
source there is still undeniable
chemistry between them and everyone
around them can feel it I really think
when you know you know and
um she's been one of my best friends
since I was like 15 years old well we
wait to see how all this play
is
[Music]